hey Tom I got to ask you one last
question
um if you could go back and change
everything that happened which would you
go back and change it my side's always
20 20 man okay so you wouldn't go back
and change everything that happened like
as far as the cheating you wouldn't
go back and change that
like I just said hindsight's always 20
20. it's like
so you're just you're looking forward
like everything that happened in the
past happened like yeah like when you
hitting like
yeah
you know
um
do you have do you have any regrets at
all about you what why do you feel like
you're getting so much heat considering
I've watched the show like I'm not gonna
lie I I really had no clue about the
show like that much and now that I've
watched a lot everyone cheated on the
show why do you think you're getting the
most heat out of like everyone else
that's cheated on I just think it was
really unexpected okay so just because
it came out of nowhere and
okay
all right
all right is that your that's that's a
sound bite that's you know it's just a
little sound bite you know what
hindsight
think of all the things that you should
have would have done oh okay got better
I didn't know I thought it was more like
the future like you're looking towards
hindsight like looking back at like when
you handle a situation like yeah yes I
could have handled things way better
okay yeah all right so you do regret
cheating on like you know maybe you
could have done it way better and of
course Kevin okay of course all right
thank you